you
[music] It
's not a suicide note
Hey, you're jumping in the back Really
[music]
I'm healed
Thank you mom
Mamoru-san celebrates
, so be careful
Stones, cars, crows, riverbeds, etc. I'm going
today suddenly
true
[music]
haha
Yes,
solder
[music] Hmm,
grandma, are you okay now?
It's okay, my head is messy hahaha It's okay, I
'll help you.
No
, waiting for Izumi-san is fun
too, but it seems like you've been having a hard time since this morning
too.
Isn't it poisonous?
Don't do it
[Music] It
's so cool
I'm more happy than I
am  I want to enter
naniI didn't aim for that daySa ah
ah
I
got my heart paired three lies
yahoo
amaran
cute aa
anaI went to God and came back and I don't have it
You were beautiful at last year's entrance ceremony
, right?
Izumimura, I'm nervous
.  It
doesn't sound like Mari to Zoe Nets, after
all I want to be in the same class as my favorite Mori-san
, so it's
okay.  I
haven't reached the
bar
.  Thank you
.
I wonder if I'm the only one who got overwhelmed 9 times
Oh,
that
's right.
Teru na
[music] From
today onwards, you're all in a position to be called seniors.
You'll be the centerpiece of school events, right?
Let's make this a fun year
.
First of all, Izumi-kun, in order of attendance number
[Laughter] I'm
in my second year of high school today
.
Thank you
House
Okura 6
I'm fine.
In the
first place, where did the blackboard eraser come from?
We are too, but I'm
so
envious of
you
.
Kimori-
san, it's okay Yes, Izumi-san, can I go with you to the library
?
I don't think so, but
I don't think you need to worry about what I said earlier, no
matter what,
my girlfriend is cute
, but if Shikimori-san got hurt because of me, I wouldn't like
it.
Where are
you going home today? Inuzuka-kun, I don't have a part-time job today.
I have to go to Mr.
Because the cicadas are also going to play Oh, we ca
n't all play together Shall
we deepen our evolution?
It's just
me, you guys too
[Music] The
guy who loses is the one who treats the tallest guy I'll
accept it Dentist's egg shop 5th place I remember full of motivation  It's
about 23 times
I'm also similar I
'm looking forward to the time and effort
Komaba Kita I'll
choose a bol
I'll let you hold it, this girl b
But a woman's clumsiness, such as dropping her head, will
be converted into river water Alright,
let's start
from me
Hugh
ran
Ah yes, the same Straker Is it
impossible?
Bach
Hey, pretty good food
Yana me [music] rar
Cat Jackie, don't
break the silver
[music]
I know
you two, along the street
Wasted by Eh
What's wrong
I'm sure you're a cute one Water is an exercise school
What a
game without one after another
Well,
Mr. Izumi, please enter
Eh
d
I wonder if I'll go like this
Bach
Come on, come on,
mama is home, but
next month, Molly,
Mi-chan, I
know, you
want him to say you're cute, right?
[music] eh ha ha [music]
kill
ok de geso
[music]
rar
nanohana monster?
[music]
[applause]
cool
I can't see
anything but I'm
the one who chose cool over good Aryu
Hey
[music]
Oh yeah, the
loser would buy the best person Oh, that's
fine.
Oh
, but that's what I always do, and
that's good
.  Nice
rice
Are you okay
Hmmm
Why can you catch a newspaper with
a no-look?
Amazing
Thank you very much, Mr.
Shikimori I'm really sorry
I always say that I don't need 5 years,
right
?  Please don't
mind me, but
I'm sorry that I've always had you protect me [music] I love
you,
Mori-san.  I haven't given you anything
[music]
At this rate,
I'm a
little tan
tan
Izumi-san
[music]
Just stay by my side It
doesn't matter to
me what people say about me From now on, I'll do whatever I want  I'll protect you, so
after
all my
girlfriend is cool I like that kind of girl
, so what's with this timing
[music]
I didn't feel like I
'm sweating all year
Cold insulation
It
's just a coincidence, but it's just a coincidence I saw her really, really, really, really, really okay farmer
Iizumi-san, are you okay?
[music]
ani
place yes
[music]
me
rapture I want to
get married, the wind is cool and
nice princess
me
[music]
[applause]
me
's people are cool
ni
he
[applause]  ]
ni
ana
yeah yeah yeah
me
[music]